CONGRESS AND PRESIDENT TRUMAN
ESTABLISHED A NATIONAL DAY OF
PRAYER AS A YEARLY EVENT.
AND PRESIDENT REAGAN DESIGNATED
THE FIRST THURSDAY IN MAY
FOREVER MORE.
BUT OUR DEVOUT CATHOLIC
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF RAISED SOME
EYEBROWS TODAY BY NOT MENTIONING
THE WORD GOD DURING HIS NATIONAL
DAY OF PRAYER PROCLAMATION.
THE FIRST PRESIDENT EVER TO DO
SO.
PERFECT GUEST TO DISCUSS THE
ISSUE JOINING ME NOW REVEREND
FRANKLIN GRAHAM.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE DAY, I SAW
YOU PUT OUT A FACEBOOK POST JUST
MOMENTS AGO REACTING TO THE
REALITY THAT JOE BIDEN DIDN'T
EVEN MENTION GOD.
HOW CAN YOU DO THAT ON THE
NATIONAL DAY OF PRAYER?
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NOT SURE THAT HE EVEN KNOWS.
IT WAS PROBABLY A STAFF PERSON
THAT WROTE IT AND MAYBE NOT EVEN
RAN IT BY HIM BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK JOE BIDEN WOULD HAVE
APPROVED THAT ONE.
THIS IS A NATIONAL DAY OF
PRAYER.
OF COURSE WE NEED TO CALL ON
GOD.
NOT JUST SOME GENERIC GODS OR
SOME POWER IN THE AIR ON GOD
HIMSELF, THE CREATOR WHO MADE
AND CREATED THIS EARTH AND WHO
SENT HIS SON, JESUS CHRIST OF
HEAVEN TO THIS EARTH TO SAVE
MANKIND FROM SIN BY DYING ON A
CROSS AND GOD RAISED HIM TO
LIFE.
AND WE -- THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
TO PRAY TO EXCEPT TO GOD.
AND FOR JOE BIDEN TO MISS THAT I
JUST THINK MAYBE IT WAS A
STAFFER THAT DID THAT AND HE
WASN'T EVEN AWARE.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> Pete: VERY GRACEFUL FROM YOU
TO DO SO.
LET'S HOPE, INDEED, THAT IS
CORRECT.
I'M IN THE WRONG CAMERA NOW I'M
IN THE RIGHT ONE.
REVEREND, REAL QUICK, THE IDEA
OF PRAYER, THE POWER OF PRAYER,
YOU KNOW, SOME PEOPLE DISMISS IT
CHURCH ATTENDANCE IS DOWN.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO PEOPLE WHO
DOUBT THE POWER OF PRAYER?
>>
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL CHURCH
ATTENDANCE IS DOWN BECAUSE
CHURCHES HAVE BEEN CLOSED BY THE
PRESIDENT, BY DIFFERENT
GOVERNORS ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
SO, YES, CHURCH ATTENDANCE IS
DOWN WHEN YOUR CHURCH IS CLOSED.
BUT, WE FOUND THE CHURCHES THAT
ARE CLOSED THE ONES THAT WERE
ONLINE ACTUALLY HAD MORE PEOPLE
WATCHING ONLINE AND GIVING WENT
UP.
SO, I THINK WE JUST NEED TO LOOK
AT MAYBE THIS NEXT YEAR AND SEE
WHERE WE ARE.
BUT, THE POWER OF PRAYER, NO
QUESTION, GOD ANSWERS PRAYER.
HE HEARS PRAYER.
HE LISTENS TO PRAYER.
BUT WE HAVE GOT TO APPROACH GOD
IN THE RIGHT WAY.
WE HAVE TO CONFESS OUR SINS AND
ASK FOR HIS FORGIVENESS.
AND NOT GO TO HIM WITH DIRTY
HANDS SO TO SPEAK BUT WITH A
CLEAN HEART.
AND ASK HIM ALWAYS TO ASK THAT
YOUR WILL BE DONE BECAUSE GOD
WANTS THE BEST FOR US.
HE DOESN'T WANT THE WORSE.
HE WANTS THE BEST.
>> Pete: ABSOLUTELY.
>> WE HAVE TO ALWAYS ASK GOD'S
WILL TO BE DONE.
>> Pete: REVEREND, WE ARE A
FLAWED NATION LIKE EVERY, WE ARE
ALL SINFUL HUMAN BEINGS IN NEED
OF GOD'S REDEMPTION.
WOULD YOU BE WILL TO OFFER OF A
BRIEF WORD OF PRAYER FOR US ON
THE PROGRAM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
FATHER, WE PRAY FOR OUR COUNTRY,
PRAY FOR THE PRESIDENT.
FATHER, WE PRAY FOR ALL THE
FOLKS THERE AT FOX NEWS.
FATHER, WE THANK YOU FOR THEM.
AND WE JUST PRAY FOR PETE AND
HIS FAMILY.
THANK YOU, FATHER, THAT YOU LOVE
US, YOU CARE FOR US, AND THAT
YOU SENT YOUR SON, JESUS CHRIST
FROM HEAVEN TO THIS EARTH TO DIE
FOR OUR SINS AND OUR PLACE AND,
FATHER, IT'S MY PRAYER THAT MANY
PEOPLE PUT THEIR FAITH AND TRUST
IN HIM IN JESUS' NAME REPRAY,
AMEN.
>> Pete: AMEN.
FRANKLIN REVEREND GRAHAM,
REVEREND FRANKLIN GRAHAM THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THE CRUSADES YOUR FATHER DID
BILLY GRAHAM, ONE IN MINNEAPOLIS
AND ONE IN NEW YORK CITY HELPED
CHANGE MY LIFE AND SHAPE MY WIFE
AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE MISSION
YOU CONTINUE TO DO TO SPREAD THE